Was hilft gegen Husten?
Gegen Husten, leichtes Abhusten und Hustenreiz
helfen zahlreiche natürliche Hausmittel,
dieses zu lindern Eignen diese sich jedoch
bei allen Formen vom Husten gleichermaßen?
Schnupfen und Heiserkeit begleiten den Husten
als typische Erkältungssymptome.
Husten zeigt sich ebenfalls als Beschwerden
bei vielen anderen Erkrankungen, darunter
Raucherhusten (chronisch obstruktive Lungenerkrankung;
COPD), Asthma, Tuberkulose und anderen Infektionskrankheiten.
Mit Hausmitteln kann nur bedingt der Hustenreiz
gelindert werden.
Beschwerden, die über Wochen anhalten, sollten
unbedingt von einem Arzt untersucht werden.
Husten und die Ursachen
Husten ist heftiges Ausatmen gegen geschlossene
Stimmritze und diese öffnen sich dann plötzlich.
Der ausströmende Atem kann eine Geschwindigkeit
bis zu 100 Kilometer in der Stunde erreichen.
Husten ist ein Schutzreflex und schützt die
Atemwege vor Fremdkörpern oder anderen eindringenden
Reizstoffen.
Das Sekret beim Aushusten bildet sich hauptsächlich
bei einer Entzündung und ist ein natürlicher
Reflexmechanismus.
Husten ist oft sehr harmlos, zeigt sich dieses
Symptom mehrere Wochen, sollte dringend ein
Arzt aufgesucht werden.
Wann tritt Husten auf?
Husten kann bei einigen Erkrankungen auftreten,
an erster Stelle eine Erkältung.
Andere Ursachen:
• Verschlucken: Krümel oder der eigene
Speichel gelangen in die Luftröhre.
Durch Husten wird dieses wieder heraus befördert.
• Strapazen: Trockene Raumluft oder langes
Sprechen sind reine Strapazen für Hals und
Stimme.
Der Husten befördert Sekret aus den Bronchien
in den Hals und Kehlkopf und wirkt dann wie
Balsam.
• Nervosität: Anspannung macht sich mit
leichtem, nervösem Hüsteln bemerkbar.
Vor öffentlichen Auftritten befreit das Hüsteln
die belegte Stimme.
• Rauchen: Beim Rauchen werden Flimmerhärchen
der Bronchien angegriffen und es kommt in
den Drüsen zur vermehrten Schleimbildung.
Durch Husten wird versucht, das Verschleimen
zu entfernen.
Ein Infekt der Atemwege zeigt sich oft mit
einem trockenen Reizhusten, also ohne Auswurf.
Weitet sich die Entzündung aus, entsteht
Schleim und dieser wird als Sekret abgehustet.
Der aufgesuchte Arzt fragt normalerweise nach
diesem Sputum (abgehustetes Sekret).
Ist das Sekret bereits etwas grünlich, liegt
der Verdacht einer bakteriellen Entzündung
nahe und dann ist oft ein Antibiotikum erforderlich.
Liegt jedoch ein viraler Infekt vor, ist ein
Antibiotikum nicht ausreichend.
Ein krankhafter Husten begleitet fast jede
Atemwegserkrankung.
Dazu zählen:
• Erkältung, Bronchitis oder Grippe
• Asthma
• Lungenentzündung
• Keuchhusten
• Allergischer Husten (eventuell Nebenwirkung
auf Medikamente)
• Bei Kindern: Krupp und Pseudokrupp
• chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel
Lungenfibrose, Sarkoidose oder Lungenkrebs
Husten und natürliche Hausmittel
Jede Art von Husten verlangt viel Trinken:
Der Rachenraum wird bei trockenem Reizhusten
durch Trinken befeuchtet, das versorgt die
Schleimhäute und lindert den Hustenreiz.
Der Schleim, der auf den Bronchien und im
Rachenraum liegt, wird durch die Flüssigkeit
beim bildenden Husten mit Auswurf verdünnt.
Somit löst sich dieser besser und es kann
besser abgehustet werden.
Ob zum Verdünnen kalte oder heiße Getränke
besser geeignet sind, kann nicht definitiv
gesagt werden.
Denn jeder Mensch reagiert unterschiedlich.
Bei einigen Menschen kann kalte Luft oder
Getränke einen zusätzlichen Hustenreiz bewirken.
Bei anderen hustenlindernd, da die Schleimhäute
durch Kälte abschwellen.
Der Husten wird bei vielen Menschen durch
Wärme gelindert und das Wohlbefinden wird
erhöht.
Deshalb werden oft warme Getränke vorgezogen,
denn Wärme entspannt den Körper und der
warme Dampf legt sich wohltuend auf die angegriffenen
Schleimhäute.
Tee bei Husten
• Kräutertee: Diese besitzen bei Husten
unterschiedliche Wirkungen.
Einige Kräuter lösen den Schleim, andere
trocknen aus oder beruhigen.
Je nach Bedürfnissen sollten lindernde Tees
selbst zusammengestellt werden:
• Kamillentee: Kamille beruhigt die angegriffenen
Schleimhäute, neigen jedoch austrocknend.
Bei trockenem Reizhusten nicht zu empfehlen.
• Fencheltee: Fenchel löst den Schleim
und hilft bei festsitzendem Husten.
In diesem Tee kann Fenchelhonig aufgelöst
oder vorab pur eingenommen werden.
• Salbeitee: Salbei ist bei trockenem Husten
zu empfehlen, denn Salbei enthält ätherische
Öle.
Die Schleimhaut wird damit überzogen
und lindert den Hustenreiz.